est il temps de revoir ce dispositif qui
date de 1920 alors un il était temps 2
je me rappelle il ya quelques mois lors
du projet de loi de finances de
l'émotion autour du verrou de bercy
lorsque nous avions dit qu'une mission
était en cours les oppositions nous
avait un peu de temps c'est ce qui
manque savait pas où la mission allait
atterrir et bien voyez la mission a
atterri et moi je suis à l'écouté
l'atterrissage de la mission
d'information
je voulais quand même partagé une chose
avec vous qu'on sait pas forcément à
cette heure c'est que c'est la première
fois depuis bientôt un an
moi je suis parlementaire et que
j'essaie tonnard que l'ensemble des
groupes et des parlementaires peu
importe les origines politiques sont
d'accord sur les conclusions d'un
rapport parlementaire ça n'est pas rien
ça veut dire que deux eric coquerel à
charles de courson en passant par la
république en marche au tour d'emilie
carew mais aussi du président diard nous
sommes tous d'accord avec les
conclusions qui ont été remises
l'idée simple il ya à peu près 15 mille
dossiers instruits au clan fiscales par
an mil arrive au pénal jean louis
bourlanges à une expression autres
sympathiques et qu'à un tuyau de
distillation entre les 15000 et les 1000
l'objectif c'est de croiser comme l'a
dit émilie carew à juste titre les
expertises à la fois du fisc et des
tribunaux s'il y a que le fisc on n'est
pas assez efficient et on le voit
aujourd'hui s'il n'y a que les tribunaux
on manque d informations fiscales donc
il faut qu'on ait une dynamique croisés
l'objectif était assez simple c'est
d'aller chercher les gros fraudeurs
parce qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on se
concentre sur ceux dont la pratique
quotidienne et la fraude fiscales donc
sur la forme j'aurais quand même dire
que ça fait plaisir aussi de voir que
sur certains sujets qui sont techniques
on arrive à bosser dans l'apaisement et
on arrive à trouver des solutions
directs permanents s'y opposent eh bien
écoutez c'est le jeu je pense que c'est
intéressant et nous allons avoir la
discussion c'est le jeu nous sommes le
parlement nous ils devaient tous salué
la décision du maire devant des échanges
mais je pense qu'il est très important
comme le disait le président que c'est
pas donné les clés du verrou de bercy
aux parlementaires c'est faire en sorte
que les parlementaires par les gîtes de
la loi puisse revoir et amender les
critères de gravité pour pouvoir entamer
procédure pénale c'est extrêmement
important et je pense qu'aujourd'hui ça
fait partie aussi des des requêtes que
les parlementaires ont le droit de
porter légitimement